we've been talking on today's show about
the road map to easing lockdown
that the prime minister will announce
tomorrow matt hancock said earlier that
it's still being worked on and when i
spoke this week to lord hague the former
foreign secretary and conservative
leader
i asked him what he wants to hear from
boris johnson tomorrow
well i think as with most people i'm
hoping to hear that
before too long the great majority of
restrictions on people can be
lifted and now he's presumably going to
say that that will depend
on the progress that is being made and
that's fair enough
um but i think if we are going to reach
the point
perhaps in april where everybody over
the age of 50
has been has had the opportunity to be
vaccinated
and the number of cases of covid
is down to a very low level the at the
sort of level
we last saw in the middle of the summer
last year if
both of those things have happened by
some time in april
then there wouldn't be much
justification for keeping most of the
restrictions
on people i think with one big caveat
there has to be a deal as it were
between the government and the people of
this country
that we have to do the mass testing when
we reach that point we have to be ready
for really
rapid ruthless local lockdowns
we have to all join making a test and
trace system work which it can do once
the infections are at a lower level
so everybody has to be psychologically
ready for that
and if they are then i think at that
point the government can really release
most of the restrictions and back in
june
you said that lockdown was a disaster
for our society an economic
catastrophe and so destructive that it
can only ever be allowed
once logged as i explained when i wrote
that
article represents the failure of other
policies it's what you do when
every other means of containing a
pandemic has
failed so that means you don't have
effective test and tracing that you
haven't managed to seal the borders that
you haven't managed to
identify through testing the the rise of
the virus
again it's a policy failure really to
have
a lockdown but of course coming in
through 2021 we ought to be in a
position with the development
of mass testing with a test and trace
system that can work at a lower level of
uh
infection and with the huge success of
the vaccination
program great credit to the government
about that
with all of those things well then we do
have the tools now to prevent
future lockdowns i think there are
lessons
now you know and some of them we've just
been talking about
we must have mass testing well that that
couldn't have been developed last summer
um but it can be put all put in place
now
uh the test and trace system has
struggled
but it's partly struggled because
there's still such a high level of
infection to deal with and i think we
have learned that if we
are going to have long terms you have to
do them quickly
the faster you take the action the
better so when it comes
in that this um whatever point it is
later this year that i was talking about
but the government says well you're free
of most restrictions
but we have to be really ruthless and
quick
if the virus rears its head again in a
particular town or city
or locality uh well then they have to be
ready to act
very very fast on those situations or
on the risk of the virus coming back in
again with a mutation from
overseas talking about the way that uh
number 10 has handled
the crisis do you think there's been any
improvement since the changes
of personnel the departure of uh dominic
cummings and lee kane haven't always
been the biggest fans then
i think that has been a big improvement
actually and
i pointed this out recently uh i've not
i don't i don't want to personally
attack the people who left they were
brilliant people but maybe running
government
wasn't their greatest skill compared to
running campaigns
uh well now some people have been
brought in who are very good at running
government you know though the prime
minister has a new chief of staff he's
made other recent appointments
and it's it you can tell over the last
couple of months that
government has worked better there's
been more
under-promising and over-delivering
rather than the other way around there
have been fewer rows
have been fewer destructive leaks and
side briefings to the press you can just
tell you can smell it that
things have improved and the way things
work can come and the public can smell
it
as well one of the big challenges ahead
of course is the budget
what would you like to see in that
budget well the big task for the
chancellor has been
keeping as many people as possible in
work and the economy
ready and intact for the future over the
last year and i think he's done that
very well what is the next task well the
next task is for britain to be at the
forefront
of what i think will be an extraordinary
decade of
innovation coming up uh all over the
world
this is partly a result of the pandemic
partly the result of a technological
race going on between the
the us and china i think a really
important thing to look out for
in the budget is is this country
positioning itself
for that wave of innovation are we going
to have the right
rules and laws and incentives and
cooperation between
government and the private sector and
the right tax
rates to achieve that it's very
important not to disincentivize people
to invest in the businesses of the
future
you know people talk about reforming
capital gains tax well
there may well be some very important
and worthwhile reforms that can be made
of it
but it's really important not to tax
people away
from entrepreneurship from risk-taking
from investing in things that might fail
in the future
as well as all the things that are going
to succeed
so um it's the chancellor's job to work
all that out
um you touched on some of the kind of
global challenges that i'm quite keen to
talk about and
particularly china what kind of
relationship do you think we should be
looking to create
postcoded with china there's obviously
these concerns about human rights abuses
should we be tacking towards the eu
position which is obviously
has china as one of their biggest
trading partners or should we adopting
the american stance more concerned about
china
well if you put it that way i would say
uh more the american
stance but it isn't just a
straightforward a choice
uh as that i think the eu for instance
made a
mistake signing their new investment uh
treaty
with agreement with china just before
the biden administration came in without
consultation with the united states
we actually need western countries to
put their heads together much more on
policy towards china and hopefully
when the prime minister hosts the g7 in
cornwall later this year that sort of
thing
will be on the agenda and can be
achieved but what is the right approach
well i would say it's a hard-headed
approach
it's neither um one of um it's not the
golden age of friendship but it's not
unremitting hostility either it is an
approach where we say well we can't
allow ourselves to be dependent on china
for key technologies in the future that
means we do have to restrict
some of the investments they've tried to
make in this country or the takeover of
british companies
by chinese entities we do have to make
sure for instance all the
the batteries for instance that we need
for electric vehicles in the future
aren't made in china so that we're
dependent on that supply chain
but at the same time we can't solve
global problems without china
we can't stop the next pandemic now we
can't
stop climate change we can't have arms
control
we can't uh deal with a future financial
crisis
without working with china facebook has
blocked
news feeds in australia now this is in
response to this law requiring
tech giants to actually pay news
providers for content
do you think facebook has got this wrong
would you like to see other countries
adopting the australian model of asking
tech
giants to pay news providers for content
social media companies like facebook
have done a lot of good of course in
connecting
people up in in absolutely revolutionary
new ways and the many human benefits of
that
but there's a lot of harm taking place
as well
and that harm includes to the to the
fabric of democracy
uh diminishing for instance uh local
newspapers and traditional news
outlets whose diversity and whose
availability is
is an important part of a free and
democratic society
and particularly feeding polarization
by adjusting news so that it suits the
individual
so that it reinforces the the views of
that individual rather than exposing
them to
wider views so yes i hope other
countries including the uk
will take a similar position we talked a
lot about some of the really big
challenges
um you know facing us at the minute
whether it's china
covid social media companies and
one big thing of course on boris's
johnson's entree is
scotland and the challenge a potential
referendum could cause how concerned are
you
about the prospect of scotland voting
for
independence if there is a referendum
and if there is then boris johnson's not
going to be the person to
lead the campaign for the unionism well
i'm very concerned
about that um i can tell everybody
having been the foreign secretary
of the uk that british standing
in the world the influence of the
british people including the people of
scotland
in the world if we were to break up the
uk
would be very seriously diminished uh
this would be um
a bigger event than than brexit it would
have a bigger impact than anything
whatever your views on on brexit
on the standing of the uk on our ability
to exercise our influence
in the world where we are much more than
the sum of our parts
so i think this would be a catastrophic
development
we got kirstarma on the show at this
weekend as well
um obviously of course there are certain
challenges at the minute for labour
is the government's enjoying a kind of
vaccine bounds if you like
if you've got any advice that you'd give
to a leader of the opposition who is
grappling with a newly elected
government off the back of a landslide
election
it's a very thankless task unless people
think you're about to become
prime minister and people will try and
push you around all the time
uh and and try to we've just seen this
with the speech that kiersta alma gave
the last
few days uh try to over hype what you're
about to say this is a re-launch
you know and uh then you end up taking
part accidentally in a relaunch of
yourself
and then of course everybody's
disappointed and a few weeks later you
have another relaunch
and you end up looking a bit ridiculous
um
so i think sometimes it's better just
keep your head down for a bit
if the government's doing well and let
that wash over you
and still be there uh when the
atmosphere has
changed um thank you so much for being
on the programme mr hager it's
very interesting to talk thank you thank
you very much